all right
ryan yes sir ryan uh where you from
where'd you grow up
um new orleans born in the city zoo
which is
charity hospital in the 70s and tell me
about your
childhood you had both your parents when
you were a kid uh for the most part
um they were both drug addicts
um dad was a real bad alcoholic
uh my mother was um poly substance abuse
you know she did a lot of different
drugs um
i was born addicted to methadone and
heroin and
alcohol for sure um i was real sick as a
child
i was in an oxygen tent for about six
months when i was born because my lungs
collapsed
i had celiac disease and also um i had
real bad colic
and uh i was so it was so bad that my
mom would actually beat me because i was
sick and my grandmother would have to
come and get me in fear of
my mom's gonna kill me you know and she
would literally bring me to my
grandmother's house because she was
scared she was gonna kill me
you know so but um yeah childhood wasn't
um
all that great in the beginning but as i
started to get a little bit better
childhood was very dysfunctional by far
um you know we always had
a lot of people at the house um my dad
being a biker from the galloping gooses
and um
you know and hanging out with uh a lot
of people from
big organizations you know
and you uh you got how far in school i
made it to the sixth grade
sixth grade yeah and where'd you go i
mean
why did you stop then um just getting
um well i tell you what happened was
um i accidentally shot my friend
uh around that time and uh it was just
when i was starting to come out of my
shell as um
not being very sociable but when i shot
my friend it wound up
killing everything that i had built in
school so i became an outcast and nobody
liked me no more because i shot a friend
of everybody's
and a very good friend of mine's in my
house um
with a 22 long range rifle um it was an
accident
in a sense because i forgot that when
you put the clip in the gun that it
loads one in the chamber if you pull a
wrap back
so i shot him and he almost hit his
finger and he almost died
um you know so i just quit school
and went on my own you know thing
uh really closed and became real
almost a hermit for quite a long time
you know and um started to i was already
kind of doing drugs
um you know huffing different freon and
scotchgard and smoking marijuana i had
did some pain pills and um
snorted a little coke and did i ask and
did pretty much the full gambit except
for
what wound up becoming my main drug
being heroin but um
yeah it was it's pretty quick start
to my whole um addicted lifestyle did
the guilt
you felt about shooting your friend well
of course i had to you know
i felt like i had to dull the sharp
that's a reality to cope with everyday
existence
you know my um i had a girlfriend at the
time when i shot him and i went to jail
for
quite a few weeks after i shot him in
juvenile jail and um
you know i was really really this was my
first love and i loved her so much and
she stuck with me through it but
you know when i got out it was a big
fiasco because my mom and dad was
getting divorced at the time
and uh my father tapped the phone and
everything out my phone calls to my
mother and
all kinds of it was just it was terrible
uh waiting outside with rifles in
her bushes gonna kill her husband her
um we had to go get him out of mental
hospitals it was really bad
you know and at the same time i had to
look out for my little sister you know
and that's what really mattered to me
the most at that time was making sure
she didn't get involved in everything
that was going on he died
no no he hasn't now he's one of my best
friends i mean we're back friends and
you know um he's a great uh brother
um and he wasn't never supposed to have
kids and he wound up having five of them
and
he's married to a good friend of ours
and he works offshore and he's
always a real good friend to me even to
this day you know he
checks up on me on facebook when he sees
i'm active when i got a phone
you know um like all everybody on my
facebook is mostly
like people that i grew up with you know
so today you live where you're on the
street
oh i'm on the streets i've been on the
streets quite some time now um
i've done a lot of time in prison you
know um about 27 years out of my 43
years on earth i've been in prison what
kind of conditions
um most of my convictions are um drug
related
if it's not a drug offense it'll be
shoplifting or grand larceny um
the negligent injury and uh temp
homicide and some other things but
nothing um no sex offenses or nothing
like that
you know just um basically everything
that had to do with obtaining
the drugs yeah so what do you do for
money today
today um anything
you know i mean i i've done it all from
prostitution to escort to
robbery to stealing to
everything you know prostitution meaning
oh yeah i've been a prostitute
really yeah oh yeah i'm in quite a few
cities and
quite a few mixes of the gay scene that
was really popular at the time
christopher street
in new york when it was around prospect
park um
the time and it was really popular uh
hiv is running rampant
um in hollywood here um on santa monica
boulevard
um i worked for one of the biggest
escort companies in uh
houston texas called a bash
entertainment i did a lot of escorting
um
i danced at the corner pocket when i was
real young like 17 which is a
gay bar in new orleans that lets
underage kids
dance there you know um you know and
then i prostituted in new orleans quite
a
while you know with uh the little strip
you know where everybody is that are you
gay
um i'm not i well i identify my sexual
preference is money
basically but uh you know i mean
i was with a um trans gender for almost
10 years you know
but i also have you know baby moms and
and you know i'm saying
i see your children yeah yeah how many
kids do you think you have i got
well i think i had three yeah
my son i actually know he's mine but
it said which is the whole story into
itself me and his mother
were best friends since we were kids and
um she uh
came with me to hollywood on a whim on
her 18th birthday
i went to a concert with her at marilyn
manson on canal street new orleans and
sold a bunch of fake ecstasy to get
enough money for us to go to hollywood
she came with me and uh nine months
later after she left me
she had a baby which he just graduated
from high school and he's awesome
he's a friend of mine on facebook and
i've been around him his whole life but
his mother has never told me he's mine
and he don't know
and i know he is i could just look at
him you communicate with him through
facebook yes all the time
yeah but have you spent time with him at
all no like um
you know um i've been out here quite a
while quite a lot since he's been born
and i've also been in prison a lot so
yeah
this is the longest i've ever been out
of prison in my life i've never had a
run
this long which is going on about two
and a half years now
where i've not you know usually my whole
life has been 30 days out
20 days out there you know do you think
it's a year here we get
do you think it's because you're in la
now where the cops might be a little
more lenient
no i think it it was even in new orleans
i think it's
due to the revamping of the justice
system as far as drugs are concerned
i think they're starting to recognize
that drug disease is an addiction
and it's like putting somebody in jail
for cancer you know we're just shaking
out of the reagan era of the
war on drugs you know
do you have any friends um
friends uh well i'll tell you what
i have a very small circle that i would
call
friends um
one being my sister and uh one being
not my brother but he is my brother
you know he's been around us since he
found his father hung on a tree
christmas morning
and he's been around us ever since he's
just one of my greatest
you know people in my life you know
jerome good friend of mine you know
that's it though um other than that it's
just acquaintances
you know you try not to let anybody in
too deeply because
um i've suffered enough pain man i've
been through so many
traumatic you know being molested as a
child um i've been
you know raped in prison um
um see i'm still trying to figure this
out um i actually confronted my mother
with this uh when i've seen it this time
and um it was a guy on my street
i remember his name being doug he was
older and it was uh when i was very very
young
you know so that's the only thing i can
remember
tell me about the tattoos on your face
oh um
well my brother um who died um
in jail on a um toilet from septic
ulcers he bled out
and they didn't find his body so the
next morning his daughter
is elena and know she's my niece and i
love her to death and she's such a sweet
girl and she's always
never judged me you know she's always
loved the bubble for who he is you know
and um this tattoo can you turn your
face this way yeah this tattoo the cross
represents a lot of different things but
mostly
it's broken because the brokenness that
religion has done me
um you know i believe now i know for a
fact you know
um educating myself i mean even though i
graduated sixth grade now i had two
degrees and
i went to a theology school and a lot of
you know
degree in behavioral science and but uh
it just represents that brokenness of
religion who had scarred me over the
years but the guy that did these tattoos
um we grew up together since we're young
in new orleans he died two days after
doing him
he odd on fentanyl in the tattoo shop
and um
he was in the bathroom i wasn't there at
the time and they wouldn't kick the door
down without permission of the owners
and they knew he was dead so i kind of
got a conspiracy theory about that but
you know he's a good friend of mine and
you know he's now gone because
you know this terrible opioid addiction
in this
you know that's going on across the
country and louisiana new orleans
especially has the highest opioid
addiction rate
per capita in the world is that right
yeah yeah
so you know what's the most important
lesson you've learned
how old are you i'm 43 43 yeah what's
the most important lesson you've learned
in your 43 years
the most important lesson i learned is
the most important thing to me is just
being a good person to people
that i don't know instead of people that
i know i've got to be good to
i need to be good to the people that i
necessarily wouldn't be good to any
other
time you know otherwise because um i
see how different people work in
different lives and i see how good
things that you do produce good
fruit you know karma is real you know
and it and
it comes around you know you know it's
really really
a real thing you know especially on
these streets you know
all right ryan well thank you so much
for talking with me very interesting
story
and good luck out there you're welcome
thank you
you